[Music]
so the founder of Rolling Stone magazine
I don't know
um he was on Rogan
asked him about he once said that the
government the Rolling Stones guy said
that the government should regulate the
internet here's how this went went to
regulate the internet absolutely you
trust the people that got us into the
Iraq War under false pretenses to
regulate the internet uh do you think
that makes any sense well wait a minute
I would not the people who got us into
the Iraq war is the government with
enough where's the politicians which is
the government the government
what's another way to describe
government is the government
in the end yes it's the governor in the
end yeah it's the point but who else is
going to regulate but if there's nobody
nobody because the internet doesn't need
to be regulated no we need the
government regulating less things this
isn't we're we're not this isn't like
the oil industry that needs some sort of
Regulation so they don't dump crude oil
into the [ __ ] into a small town I
understand some of that [ __ ] these are
words does it if you don't listen to
them nothing happens to be fair Royce
hear me out on this right the government
regulates our educational system right
poorly and we have the smartest kids in
the world dumbest the government
regulates the environment right cleanest
environment in the world Baltimore
we regulate drugs and we beat the [ __ ]
out of that we won the drug war remember
that no we lost there's a bunch of
people in the midwest dying of drugs
that the government helped create
well yeah but eventually they'll all OD
on Fentanyl and then the fentanyl ODS
will stop and we'll have one fair enough
you're gonna be in power and they're
regulating the internet they're going to
regulate the internet in a way that
suits their best interests the same way
they do with the banking industry the
same way they do with the environment
the same way they do with energy maybe
maybe Joe had Kanye and it didn't tell
us the same way they do it with
everything what represents their
interests there's so much you're talking
about so much money involved in
disseminating information
right now or the internet companies are
rich beyond belief yeah I will just real
quick yes they are but you know what's
more Pharma which is regulated by the
government
it's fat but it's it's a disruptive
thing that has never existed before my I
I think it exists and I think where
we're at is where we're at I think we
need to move forward collectively as a
country with an ethic that
respects truth and that it appreciates
opinions and reality and and an
understanding of things that's not
necessarily possible with corporate
interest involved in dissemination of
information but there's no way to do
that except through the government
this guy's a [ __ ] everything you
described you could do without the
government being involved no we need the
government Royce there's no government
helps there's no way you can do that
except through the government human
nature is not going to change but the
but the people that run the government
are also susceptible to human nature
because they're humans correct or are
you saying Alex Jones Is Right in their
lizard people you're admitting that
they're lizards
admitted you have to marriage your
mother-in-law uh also uh into
interdimensional pedophiles also and yes
you're right I apologize government's
not going to change either but the
government is capable of change yeah
yeah changing into a worse version of
the government the government changes in
a good way
I'm sorry this guy just watched Rocky IV
via judge agents if the visor could
change the government could change
okay look the government regulates for
example the food supply
yes and our food is literally poisoned
and we have the fattest kids in the
world yeah we're literally eating
poison
work and recolate let's take the food
supply yeah that Department of
Agriculture why have they left
glyphosate infestate all of our Foods
all right Joe all right
you never know what Joe Rogan what
you're gonna get sometimes you'll just
[ __ ] be based as [ __ ] with [ __ ] and
sometimes to be like I don't care it
depends on his mood that's true when
he's cranky oh you know what it is Marsh
sober October
oh yeah and we've noticed this we've
noticed this because yeah he gets a
little pissed every October every time
he is just pissed and not because he I
don't think he's a big book he drinks a
bit but he's not a big booze hound or
anything weed he that's his thing like
that's his thing and look I know what
it's like immerse both know what it's
like to try to do a show without smoking
weed it's not fun okay it sucks
right now one thing yeah but that's the
problem that's I agree regulating well
then we better get better politicians in
them oh way better people okay I mean
it's nice better politics what were we
thinking this guy's a this guy it sounds
like Joe Rogan is interviewing a guy at
a bus station right and honestly you
would think isn't it like it's from the
way he talks to his appearance just
mush-mouthed in his dumb opinions well
we knew the gold moved through the
internet
I guess again don't let the perfect be
the enemy of the good right okay so
let's take the uh
SEC or take the Food and Drug
administration's regulates big Pharma on
the one hand we've got a very safe
supply of drugs in this country
what 25 of all drugs that get passed
through the FDA get recalled
yeah and like the majority of our drugs
are manufactured in China so we don't
where
China
we keep each other honest around here
yeah we got to keep each other yeah no
thank you thank you for auditing me we
have to we have to he's giving me a
truth on it yeah it's called audit the
sped okay that's what we do here
God that's so funny
you know you don't get too many bad
drugs you know from prescribed drugs
somebody doesn't watch daytime TV by the
way but you're right but on top of that
bro have you been not around for like
three years they just admitted they
never tested it to see if it stopped
transmission what the [ __ ]
[ __ ] bro